I want to go back to the story about
selling your house and then working in
the bar and writing the script during
the day you have to hear that story yeah
so what my best friend growing up is
this guy Brandon Barrera and we he's a
big business savvy guy and I'm the
creative guy and we he convinced me to
buy go in with him and buy this house so
we bought a house in Hollywood this was
you know I had money from Peter Pan some
other acting jobs and we had this house
and then I got into making this movie
and I'm like Brandon how about we do a
production company sell the house
finance the movie he said sure let's do
it
we financed the movie two years later
I'm broke I learned about something
called capital gains tax should know
about that before you sell house kids so
I got hit with just dozens and dozens of
thousands of dollars in bed I think with
eighty thousand at one point and you
know I was worried about having to I had
the LLC for the movie and we had this
production company and I went to work
and I was I moved into this apartment
that I called a hovel and lived there
worked every single night where where I
was working at the village idiot on
Melrose and Martel
okay which is great barn these the guys
who own the bar they had just sunk
everything they had into opening this
bar and I would come into work every
morning to pick up my tips like right as
they opened and one day my boss was like
Blaine tell me the truth do you have a
drug problem I'm like what what do you
what do you mean he's like nobody needs
80 bucks so bad that they get here at
9:00 a.m. he's like what's the deal and
I told him I just I just spent
everything I have and a lot that I don't
to make this movie and he's like well I
just did that for this restaurant so we
were in this same situation exactly and
we kind of became great friends they
were always work work me let me do
overtime to get all extra money and very
frowned on the restaurant world but they
you know we're such supporters
ironically not ironically we've become
very close me and those guys and the
after party for the LA premiere of cut
to the chase we'll be at the village
idiot which oh that's great I love
synchronicity
but yeah so I was work writing every day
get up early in the morning and I'd
write and I wrote four or five scripts
that year the year of the Havel and like
it was literally almost exactly a year
because right as the lease was running
out
weather girl came together I was able to
get out of there I got paid a proper fee
to direct you know and I got to direct
Mark Harmon and Kaitlin Olson and Jon
Cryer and Jane Lynch it was like it was
a totally different you know experience
for me and like I did there was a time
where I didn't think that would ever
happen but it was just tenacity and if I
hadn't have been in the Hubble I don't
know if I would have been as writing as
much as I was and I don't know if I
would have done whether girl so you know
I guess it paid off some that being sort
of in this really uncomfortable place or
a place that you just felt like this is
not what I wanted for my life yeah
pushed you that sounds like yeah I I
think so and you know like what's funny
is I have a weird outlet to it I guess
but like when when young people ask me
you know should I pursue this it's
acting this writing you know directing
anything in this business really I
usually say we have to look at it like
I'm being an artist or you're choosing
an artist lifestyle well if you're
choosing to be famous that's you're nuts
that's not reality you know you have to
look at it say am I willing to be broke
am I willing to have to work you know
several jobs in order to chase this
dream you know and if you're okay with
that and this is the place for you
should absolutely do it if you're not I
bet you there's lots of different
options know what I mean so like I I
kind of I try to take it with a grain of
salt just like that that down spiral
lead to weathergirl which is one of the
high points in my career so so let's
talk about when I don't know how late
you worked at the bar in terms of hours
like - oh yeah mmm and you're cleaning
up and so it's like maybe three or
whatever you're getting home yeah you're
getting up early in the morning how much
sleep are you getting Oh sleep sleep
especially those days didn't really work
into it and like the bar just opened and
it was like the new staff was always
hanging out and drinking
very late and getting up early in the
morning yay sleep didn't really work
into it very very much but like you know
another funny thing about this life is I
need to be able to audition you know and
take meetings Monday through Friday so
I'm working
those are my like I have to be available
right so Friday Saturday Sunday holidays
I'm working so where most people have
the day off that's when I go in you know
and because if LA is closed that's the
only time I can literally wait tables
all day longer you know but it was a
rough time it was a rough time I don't I
don't recommend it so how are you having
the discipline to write especially when
writing just takes this like
concentrated effort and then when you're
in another world that's maybe a little
more chaotic I think it's hard to
harness that yeah no I agree with that I
mean it's kind of like to me it's you
see how bad do you want it you know how
bad do you want this thing it's like if
I can't get up and write in the morning
then why am i waiting tables to begin
with you know I could you know I have a
college degree I go out and get some job
where you know I'm on salary and you
know I won't be able to go to auditions
I won't be able to have meetings I
certainly won't have time to write I'm
doing this so that I can write so if I'm
not writing then all that time waste is
wasted you know at that the night job
you know what I mean
does that make sense it's at like the
two things feed each other I think the
more I hate my job the more I get up in
the morning and write any any bad
customer situations that just really
fuel do and you were able to just put
them into the script oh man
first weather girl and literally
literally about a girl in the
entertainment industry she's you know a
weather person and she quits her job and
then can't get rehired because she quits
it very publicly and she has to go wait
tables it's like if that's not it's
literally what happened to me like I
made this movie I was a director actor
hotshot couldn't sell it I'm back to
waiting tables and I'm waiting on people
that you know just a
six months beforehand I would have hired
so yeah like all of those experiences
fed into you know what weather girl was
about to me why I just want to go back
to the house thing so when you sold the
house that you might have asked what
year this was uh 2005 I think oh okay so
it was on an upswing yeah it was yeah I
got out of it Edie riot or like that
would have changed everything like if I
had owned that place a little bit longer
and then the bubble happened I certainly
wouldn't have been able to finance my
movie right and did you like living
there yeah okay it was great by a hard
decision to make
was now no no no I was young and
impetuous and you know it was like I was
making a movie it was very exciting I
was not the hardest thing about making
independent films at 40 years old is I
know too much you know like I'm more
scared now than I ever was in my 20s or
even mid-thirties you know it's like now
I know that I'm risking things then I'm
just following my dream and doing cool
stuff like I had I loved being a part of
this club of directors and producers who
have gone out and made something they've
gotten they've taken a blank sheet of
paper and now there's a movie that's
there it's a small organization of
people you know who have the chutzpah
and the you know ability you know to
even get it done much less if it's good
I love it it's a very brave and you know
exciting group of people I think two
people are more forgiving of an 18 year
old or 19 year old making a mistake
sure yeah they are of someone over 30 I
think about that's another scary thing
absolutely yeah it's much less romantic
you know when you know a four year old
blows it you know 25 year old you just
learning sure sure poor thought oh I
just have to not blow it thanks Vicky
were there ever times when let's suppose
things weren't going that well that you
regretted selling the house and trying
to make this movie knowing that you'd
come from position where you were doing
well in that sense you have property in
LA that's that's not hard that's
excusing that's very hard to do but and
then you're in the hovel right were
there times when you said with
is all worth it no no because like a and
like not to say that there aren't times
where I haven't thought well that I've
made bad choices but not when it comes
to the movies the movies to me like you
know I'm not married I don't have kids
and I most of my friends would be very
offended if I compared my movie to them
having kids but to me that's what it is
like once it's come to fruition I would
never regret anything that led to
whether girl or six-month rule or cut to
the chase existing egg because it's not
just mine you know that that's one of my
favorite things about directing and you
know being the person that has to go out
and raise the money which is not
something I enjoy of course few people
do but I build a team you know and then
they count on me there's this paternal
feeling that you have towards not only
the movie itself but the people who
helped make it you owe them something
you know it's like you put your sweat
and art into the making this feature
better and it's my job to protect that
and to get it all the way through to the
to the finish line and like I could
never say ah man I wish I had made
outside sales because like outside sales
was the movie that made me a director
you know the whole reason I became a
director was a bad experience I had on
this film that called manic that I wrote
manic with another writer and I really
didn't like the director and it was a
really rough shoot for me and but it
made me think if this guy can do it I
can direct you know and like I don't
know if I would have become a director
if I hadn't have had that bad experience
on that on that shoot but I did and now
Here I am
you know four features under my belt and
you know eight produce screenplays and
like I I don't regret it like there are
things that I wish you know we'd spin a
different way but like who doesn't
you